There's a photo actually that I really love
that I wanna put up on the screen of Colin.
He was doing the Weekend Update, which is everything.
Yeah, they do a great job.
Oh my God, it's an institution.
It is, it's great.
It's so fun.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
So I guess he threw up a picture
of himself in high school--
Oh, yeah, with the mushroom cut?
Can we throw that up?
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Okay, so would high school Scar Jo be
into high school Colin?
I don't think so, no.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
No, firstly, my brother had that same haircut
throughout the...
Both of my brothers and I just can't.
There is no way.
I mean, who decided on that cut as a stylish thing?
(audience laughs)
What hairdresser was like, I'll try this?
I just love that, though.
That is so cute.
Okay, so when I watch Update religiously,
I love how much Michael Che just gives him crap
upon guff upon tease about you.
About me and at times, I think to myself
some of it goes so far that I am like
you're gonna receive hate mail.
It's so violent.
Yeah, it's pretty bad.
Yeah, Michael, you old rascal.
Is he a rascal?
What's he like in real life?
I don't know him at all.
Oh, you've never met him before?
I met him once backstage at the show and said hello.
He's gonna probably not want me to say this,
but he's the sweetest, menchiest, nicest guy.
Really?
Yes, he is.
Yeah, he says everything that everybody is thinking
but nobody can say.
That's what I love about it.
And I love when they feed each other the lines
that they have to read cold that they wrote for each other.
That's when I'm like, we're gonna be receiving hate mail.
It's just unbelievable.
I'm like, I hope everybody knows what this is.
Do you guys know what that is
when they give each other the Christmas present
that I then flops what over.
I watch it on my couch like this...
Just like, oh no!
And yet, everyone is there for it.
I know.
Look at the way he's looking at you.
I was literally in my bathroom and I was literally looking
at this picture of you guys and I was getting dressed
and I was reading a magazine and I came upon this picture
and I just thought, yes, that is the way a man is supposed
to look at his woman.
Aw, he's so sweet.
(audience applauds)
And look at you.
I know, I'm fist pumping I'm so excited.
But you're just like, oh yay, I'm having so much fun
and he's just like, that's my girl.
(audience swoons)
And it's like, man, woman, take the gender out of it.
If you could only have that knowledge
and maybe a little photographic evidence
that that person gets you and appreciates you.
Yeah, that's a really important thing.
I think just feeling seen by somebody else
and it's just to be seen is what it's all about.
(theme music)